[Music]
hey minimizers you're getting ready to
watch some footage from one of the
minimalist live events from the love
people use things tor if you'd like to
see us on the road visit
theminimalists.com
tour or you can find all of our live
events over at patreon.com slash the
minimalists enjoy
howdy i'm the last one what's your name
my name's spring best for last what is
it spring like a season hey spring hey
thanks for coming to san antonio thank
you thank you for coming um i just want
to thank you you both have been on my
journey this past year and a half cove
it has served me extremely well i've
gotten rid of half of my things and the
salvation army knows my name and address
thank you very much
um and i've learned some amazing things
and ryan you have said on a podcast once
that it's the action that makes it
happen
and um and it's so interesting to me
because it really is a spiritual path of
minimalizing so i just want to thank you
i learn from you every day so thank you
both and keep it up
my question is is that i do have an
elephant in the living room and it is an
online merchant that begins with a
and um
and i deleted the app
i've set budgets i've changed the card
that i can buy things with but this when
you started tonight's meeting you said
what do you want to get rid of this is
my toxic relationship so what can i do
you have a toxic relationship with
amazon yes
[Laughter]
yes wow
yeah
i thought she's talking about alibaba
so you want to break up with jeff bezos
basically right basically let me grab my
mic stand here i need a 24-hour divorce
it's an emergency yeah yeah i mean you
need a one-click divorce right
you start telling jokes soon as you get
the mic stand it's fine
um
oh wow wow i mean you know what you know
what's fascinating ryan
talked to you about the action
right
and that's important but
the action takes us only so far we
talked about this earlier knowing the
how to
really manifest when you understand the
why you want to get rid of the thing
and so i'm not condemning amazon um
i can understand
why it is so problematic for so many
people well why is it such a problem
it's removed all the friction from our
lives which sounds awesome who wants
friction
well try to drive with no friction you
lose all traction right it's like
driving on ice
for those of you from texas ice is
no um
so so
we've removed all the friction and so of
course you're sliding around consumerism
and you're careening from one purchase
to another it's same day shipping on
some items in some places
or next day oh my god i can't believe
right i had to wait a whole day
to get the butt wipes i ordered from
amazon
right
and um
so
there are some things you can do to
reintroduce friction to the process you
can change your password
and and log out of amazon every single
time you use it so you have this
password that's difficult to use it's
not memorized and you have to have that
additional friction right you can
implement something like the 30 30 rule
if something costs more than 30 i wait
at least 30 hours but what i'll do is
i'll put it in my cart right and on
amazon i just buy things one day a week
on amazon so i put it all on my cart and
then sunday rolls around i look at the
cart
and i delete ninety percent of the cart
usually some weeks it's a hundred
percent what the hell was i doing
and and then it's like i felt like i was
because it was one click not purchase
i just deleted all of it right
but that's the how-to stuff and you're
going to keep struggling until you
understand the why behind it because
amazon can be great it can get you stuff
that you want without having to go to
you know wherever um i don't even know
where people go these days walmart
um uh target etc um macy's um
these will all be outdated references in
like six months
and and so
you will
yeah it makes it convenient but if
if you prize convenience over everything
else you're going to suffer oh tweet
that yeah
wait say that again
what did you just say surprise
convenience
over everything else you were going to
suffer oh yeah that's it was funny
because i was thinking yeah convenience
convenience prevents contentment
so there's even pithier what you were
saying you outpithed me
[Laughter]
um if you understand why
if you get a deep understanding of why
you
don't want amazon in your life and it
may take
removing it for a period of time what
would happen if you removed it for a
month or six months
or a year
what if you removed it for the rest of
the year
what would happen your life would become
inconvenient
but maybe you learned something through
those inconveniences
i remember i got rid of my smartphone
for two months
it was the most productive two months of
my life
same thing might be true when you remove
your number one shopping habit from your
life
thanks for your question i appreciate
you being here thank you again for
coming to san antonio come back thank
you spring thanks for being here
did you enjoy this video if so you can
listen to full episodes of the
minimalist private podcast available
exclusively on patreon visit patreon.com
the minimalists today your support keeps
our podcast and youtube channel 100
advertisement free